[TRUMPET FANFARE]
- Good afternoon.
Glad to be back with you,
friends and colleagues,
to Radcliffe Day 2018.
For those of you who
may just have arrived,
I'm Liz Cohen, dean
of the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study.
On this special day,
we are fortunate to be
joined by Radcliffe
and Harvard leaders
of the present and the future.
I would like to extend a special
welcome to Harvard President
Drew Gilpin Faust, who
is also founding dean--
[APPLAUSE]
--founding dean, as
many of you know.
OK.
[APPLAUSE]
I'll try one more time--
founding dean of the Radcliffe
Institute--
to Provost Alan
Garber, to Bill Lee,
who was the senior fellow
of the Harvard Corporation
along with other members
of the corporation
and the board of
overseers, as well
as to many other current
university leaders who are here
with us this afternoon.
On a day like today, we
are inspired to also look
towards the future.
So it is an honor to
also welcome Larry Bacow,
Harvard president-elect--
[APPLAUSE]
--and Tomiko Brown-Nagin, the
incoming dean of the Radcliffe
Institute, who will take over--
[APPLAUSE]
--who will take over when
I step down on June 30.
And we have a record number of
past Radcliffe medalists here
today.
That includes Drew Faust,
as well as former Secretary
of State Madeleine Albright,
former Chief Justice
of the Massachusetts Supreme
Judicial Court Margaret
Marshall, and Linda Greenhouse,
long-time distinguished Supreme
Court Analyst for
The New York Times.
Today is also a celebration
of the achievements
of The Radcliffe
Campaign, Invest in Ideas.
I'll say more about
that in a moment.
But let me thank all the
current and former members
of the Radcliffe
Dean's Advisory Council
and the Schlesinger
Library Council, members
of the Radcliffe
Associate's Program
and the Ann Radcliffe
society, and past members
of the Radcliffe College
Board of Trustees and Alumni
Association for helping
to make our campaign
such a great success.
[APPLAUSE]
And I would like to recognize
all of the Radcliffe
and Harvard alums who are
marking milestones, including
the reunion classes of '43, '48,
'53, '58, '63, '68, '73, '78,
'83, '88, '92, '98, 2003,
2008, 2013, and our newest
graduates in the class of 2018.
[APPLAUSE]
And everyone, please join
me in congratulating members
of the earliest classes
represented here today--
the classes of
1940, '41, and 42.
And they're right over there.
[APPLAUSE]
We are also thrilled to be
joined by former US Ambassador
to the United Nations and
current Radcliffe Fellow
Samantha Power.
[APPLAUSE]
And to all of the
other elected officials
and dedicated public servants
who are here with us today,
we are grateful for your work.
And we are honored
to have you here.
Finally, with all of us
gathered here together,
we do, of course, think of
the friends and classmates
who are no longer with us.
This year, we lost
Amey Amory DeFriez,
a member of the
class of '49, who
served as chair of the Radcliffe
College Board of Trustees.
Please join me in a
moment of silence for Amey
and for others we are
missing this afternoon.
The Radcliffe Institute
supports and broadly shares
bold ideas,
transformative research,
and daring creative work that
is both timely and timeless.
It has been a profound
honor and privilege
to lead and grow this Institute
for the past seven years.
As I prepare to step
down, I am especially
pleased to be able to
share with you some
of the highlights of the
outstanding academic year that
concludes with today's event.
Since January, we
have been celebrating
the 75th anniversary of
our Schlesinger Library
on the history of
women in America.
[APPLAUSE]
The commemorative exhibition
"75 Stories, 75 Years"
documenting the lives
of American women
at the Schlesigner Library will
be open to all of you at 2:30
PM today and is on
view until November 1.
Other programs
celebrating the library
will continue
throughout next fall.
Across the yard in the
Johnson-Kulukundis Gallery
and Byerly Hall is a
student-centered exhibition
suitable for commencement week.
It's entitled "Art in the Yard--
Students Make Art
Public at Radcliffe."
This exhibition celebrates
the imaginative student
designs that we have installed
in the Wallach Garden
since 2013.
Art in the Yard will also
be open this afternoon
and remain on view
through June 30.
This year's annual science
symposium, titled "Contagion,"
explored new ways to understand,
track, respond to, and even
predict modern epidemics
from infectious diseases
to the opioid crisis.
An accompanying year-long
lecture series on the science
of epidemics engaged with
topics including fibromyalgia,
obesity, and
Alzheimer's disease.
Throughout the year, workshops
and public events at Radcliffe
explored the complexity of
citizenship broadly defined.
Our flagship annual
gender conference
interrogated the
question, who belongs,
bringing a gendered lens to
the topic of citizenship,
which is increasingly fraught
both at home and abroad.
Our programmatic
focus on citizenship
is timed in part to anticipate
and to contextualize the 2020
centennial of the passage of
the women's suffrage amendment,
and it will continue through
the next academic year.
In September, we will
also welcome more than 50
outstanding new fellows
from 11 countries who
will write novels and
poetry, chart massive stars,
create new art, explore the
politics of gender quotas,
delve into the geometry of
political redistricting,
and much else.
All of this and more
is made possible
by our generous supporters.
Last year at
Radcliffe Day 2017, I
announced that the
Radcliffe Campaign
had surpassed its $70 million
monetary goal more than a year
ahead of schedule.
Today, I am delighted
to report that we
follow that up with our
most successful year of fund
raising to date.
Since the start of
the campaign, we
have received over 23,000
individual gifts representing
all 13 Harvard schools
and every graduating class
from 1933 to the present.
All together, we have raised
a phenomenal $87 million,
well over 120% of our goal.
[APPLAUSE]
Nearly 80% of the people in our
2/10 have donated to Radcliffe,
and we are deeply
grateful for your support.
And to the other 20%, I
would say, don't worry.
You still have time
to make it right.
The campaign doesn't
end until June 30.
But of course, The
Radcliffe Campaign
is about much more than dollars.
Those 23,000 gifts
are a humbling display
of confidence in the
Institute, of commitment
to our important work, and of
our common ambition for an even
stronger Radcliffe
into the future.
Thanks to the campaign,
we have expanded
our public programming,
diversified our library
collections, endowed
new fellowships, created
new opportunities for creative
work, renewed our campus,
and changed the face
of the Harvard faculty
through Radcliffe
professorships.
[APPLAUSE]
Yes, that's worth some applause.
That is a lot to be proud of.
So please join me in round
of applause for all of you,
for the entire Radcliffe
community, and for everything
that we have been able
to accomplish together
as a result of your generous
support of the Institute.
[APPLAUSE]
On a more personal
level, the campaign,
including a two-year
planning phase and then
a five-year public
phase, has perfectly
aligned with my deanship.
Although that was
challenging, I am
grateful for how it
pushed me to get out
and to partner with our key
supporters, many of whom
I now consider dear friends.
And it pushed us as an
institute to more clearly
and compellingly articulate
a vision of who we are
and what we strive to do.
Two extraordinary people have
worked very closely with me
on this campaign, our
cochairs Sid Knafel all
and Susan Wallach.
I would like to take a moment--
[APPLAUSE]
There will be
another opportunity.
I'd like to take a moment now to
extend a special thanks to both
of them.
Sid could not be here today.
But his generosity
and his leadership,
as well as the example he set
as a well-respected Harvard
hand invested in
Radcliffe's future,
were critical to our success.
Susan Wallach is a passionate
and tireless advocate
for all things
Radcliffe and has served
as a trusted advisor to me
and to all of my predecessors
while also inspiring the
incredible record-breaking
support we received from her
Radcliffe College 50th reunion
class of 1968.
Susan, I cannot--
[APPLAUSE]
I cannot emphasize
enough to you, Susan,
how grateful I am for your
partnership these past seven
years.
So would you please stand
and let us all give you
and Sid a big round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
And now, on behalf of
the Radcliffe Institute,
I am honored to recognize
Hillary Rodham Clinton
as our 2018 Radcliffe medalist.
Every year, we strive
to illuminate aspects
of our medalists' life and
work that are not widely known
but help us understand
her achievements.
You can imagine that this
was very difficult to do when
it comes to Secretary Clinton.
That so much about her
life is well-known is
a consequence of her
decades in public life
as well as the unusual level
of attention and scrutiny
she has faced and overcome
throughout her distinguished
career.
But there is still an
important story to tell.
Those who have observed Hillary
Rodham Clinton over the years
can testify to her
brilliance, her determination,
and her capacity for growth.
Not surprisingly,
those qualities
were in evidence from her youth.
Born to Hugh and Dorothy
Howell Rodham in Chicago
and raised in the suburban
Republican stronghold of Park
Ridge, Hillary was
quite naturally imbued
with the conservative
political views
of her small-businessman father.
But there were early signs that
she would chart her own, quite
different political path.
To start with,
her mother Dorothy
provided a
counterforce of sorts,
as she was, in Clinton's own
words, basically a Democrat,
although she kept it
quiet in Park Ridge.
By eighth grade,
Hillary was already
displaying independence
of mind, allowing herself
to be inspired by a Democratic
President John F. Kennedy's
ambition to put an
American on the moon.
In her excitement, Hillary
wrote a letter to NASA
volunteering her services,
only to be informed
that the astronaut training
program did not and probably
never would accept girls.
Clinton reflected years later
that this, and I quote her,
"was the first time I had hit
an obstacle I couldn't overcome
with hard work
and determination.
And I was outraged."
Not only did this
experience begin
to raise the feminist
consciousness of young Hillary,
but it also demonstrated
how passion for a goal
could motivate this junior
Nixon canvasser to reach
across the partisan divide.
Clinton's political brilliance
showed up early as well.
Her senior year in
high school, she
took the part of Barry Goldwater
in a mock presidential debate
for the 1964
presidential election.
Hillary's success outshone
candidate Goldwater's.
Her opponent in that
debate, the young man
acting as Lyndon Baines
Johnson, accepted defeat
and said of Clinton what future
rivals would also discover.
She was the brightest
person I ever knew.
When it was time to
apply to college,
Clinton was drawn
to a women's school.
Her parents offered
her some advice.
As Clinton recalled
years later, "my mother
thought I should go
wherever I wanted.
My father said I
was free to do that,
but he wouldn't pay if I
went west of the Mississippi
or to Radcliffe, which he had
heard was full of beatniks.
Smith and Wellesley, which
he had never heard of,
were acceptable."
Hillary, some of those
beatniks your father
warned you about are here today
celebrating their 50th reunion.
[APPLAUSE]
College would prove to be a
time of political transformation
for Hillary Rodham as it was
for many of her generation.
She had a few rocky weeks of
typical freshman self-doubt,
which her mother met
with, I'm quoting,
"I don't like hearing
that you would walk away
from something because you're
not as ready as you think
you should be.
Get ready."
But after that, Hillary
flourished at Wellesley.
Politics became her passion both
in her political science major
and in her extracurricular life
where she experienced something
of a political realignment.
Elected president of
Wellesley's Young Republicans
in her first year, by
Clinton's junior year,
she was supporting the anti-war
campaign of Minnesota senator
Eugene McCarthy.
That academic year, 1967-'68,
coincided with watershed
moments, including the
escalation of the Vietnam War
and the assassinations
of Martin Luther King Jr.
And Senator Robert F. Kennedy.
Those upheavals led
to massive protests
at the Democratic National
Convention in Chicago
the following summer.
Clinton, back home from an
internship in Washington DC,
found her way there.
She and a close
friend, Betsy Johnson,
drove downtown in the
Johnson's station wagon
to bear witness to
the unfolding events.
Knowing that their parents would
never have allowed them to go,
Betsy had told her mother
that she and Hillary
were headed to the movies.
For Clinton, this experience
proved not disillusioning
but rather a confirmation that
electoral politics was, and I
quote her, "the only
route in a democracy
for peaceful and
lasting change."
Clinton's political
education at Wellesley
culminated in her
well-known role
as speaker at her class's
commencement in May 1969.
Her peers elected her to be
the first ever student speaker
at a Wellesley
graduation ceremony.
Hillary's remarks foretold the
course of her later career,
recasting Otto van
Bismarck's famous quote
that politics is the art of the
possible as, and I quote her,
"the challenge now is
to practice politics
as the art of
making what appears
to be impossible possible."
[APPLAUSE]
Clinton's Wellesley
commencement speech
caught the attention
of the press,
shining the national spotlight
on her for the very first time.
But buried beneath the
headlines was a side of Clinton
that would also inform
her career going forward.
Dismayed at reports
that suggested
that she had personally attacked
a fellow speaker, Massachusetts
Republican Senator
Edward Brooke,
she warned Life magazine not
to repeat the same mistake
in their profile.
Even as a youthful
activist, Clinton
valued civility and
respect for her opponents,
not something that
was always prevalent
in those troubled times.
The Radcliffe
historians among us--
and certainly the members
of the 50th reunion class--
will remember with some pride
that Radcliffe students had
succeeded in demanding a student
commencement speaker the year
before Wellesley in 1968.
Rachel Lieberman
gave that address.
And in Lieberman's
own telling, Clinton
acknowledged to her later
that she and her classmates
might never have had the courage
to demand their own student
speaker if Radcliffe
hadn't pulled it off first.
Even if Hugh Rodham kept us from
claiming Clinton as an alumna,
we can at least take a little
credit for her early success.
The next stage after
Wellesley in Hillary
Clinton's political
evolution was her discovery
that the law was a powerful
tool for social justice.
In the fall of 1969, Clinton
entered Yale Law School,
where she was one of 27
women in a class of 235.
Clinton focused her studies
and her first scholarly article
on how the law affects children.
It was also during
her law school years
that Clinton first connected
with fellow Yale alumna Marian
Wright Edelman, founder of
the Children's Defense Fund--
and I can't resist
saying, received
the Radcliffe Medal in 1989.
As a law student, Clinton worked
with Edelman in Washington.
And then she joined the
Children's Defense Fund
full-time after
earning her JD in 1973.
In 1974 Clinton would
further hone her legal skills
on the impeachment staff of
the House Judiciary Committee
investigating President Richard
Nixon, one of only three women
attorneys out of 44.
Among Clinton's
peers at Yale Law
had been a young man
from Arkansas named Bill.
They dated.
People actually did that then.
And when Nixon resigned
in August of 1974,
Hillary joined Bill
in Fayetteville
where she became a faculty
member at the University
of Arkansas Law School.
And they married
soon thereafter.
Hillary Clinton's Arkansas
years as law professor,
as legal services activist,
as a dedicated advocate
for the state's
families and children,
and as a rare woman
partner in a major law firm
confirmed her confidence
in the law as an instrument
for achieving a better world.
Early on, she ran
a legal aid clinic
when the very idea of legal
aid was controversial.
A prominent Arkansas
judge told her,
"I don't have any use for
either lady law professors
or legal aid clinics."
She was soon appointed to the
Arkansas Committee of the Legal
Services Corporation.
And in 1977,
President Jimmy Carter
named her to the board of
the National Legal Services
Corporation.
Meanwhile, Clinton
continued her work
advocating on behalf of
women, children, and families.
In 1977, she cofounded one
of the first child advocacy
organizations in Arkansas.
She joined the board of
the Children's Defense Fund
in 1978, and she became
its chair in 1986.
And in 1987, Clinton headed
the newly established American
Bar Association Commission
on Women in the Profession.
She was also twice
recognized as one
of the 100 most influential
lawyers in the country.
While Bill Clinton was
climbing the political ladder
in Arkansas from Attorney
General to Governor,
Hillary was establishing
herself as a leader
on the state and
national levels in using
the law to redress wrongs
that had long troubled her.
Back in 1979 when Clinton
became First Lady of Arkansas,
she launched a new and more
public era in her career.
And this would culminate in her
service as Secretary of State
and her two runs for
president in 2008 and 2016.
She shifted her focus
to making policy
that improved people's lives.
About a month into her role
as First Lady of Arkansas,
Clinton gave a TV interview
on the public affairs program
In Focus.
The interviewer expressed
what many in the state
were surely thinking.
And I quote, "you really
don't fit the image
that we've created for the
governor's wife in Arkansas.
You're not a native.
You've been educated in
liberal eastern universities.
You're less than 40.
You don't have any children.
You don't use your
husband's name.
And you practice law."
Clinton responded, "I think
that each person should
be assessed and judged on
that person's own merits."
And she then proceeded
as First Lady of Arkansas
and as First Lady of the
United States beginning
in 1993 to use her
public platform
to advance an agenda for
social and political change.
Even in roles not
historically associated
with policy leadership,
Hillary found opportunities
to make a difference.
When Clinton became First
Lady of the United States,
she broke with tradition
by establishing her office
in the West Wing, clearly
signaling her intention
to play a substantive role.
Her staff became known within
the White House as Hillaryland.
Soon she took on leadership
of the Task Force
on National Health Care
Reform, a role one analyst
called "the most powerful
official post ever assigned
to a First Lady."
This was not uncontroversial.
But as she had done
before, Clinton forged
ahead, determined to make health
care a right for all Americans.
The Clinton health care
reform effort was ultimately
defeated for many reasons,
but in part because
of the resistance Clinton
acknowledge she faced,
and I quote her, "as a First
Lady with a policy mission."
While her vision for
a health care overhaul
would take almost
two decades to be
realized in the form of
the Affordable Care Act,
Clinton regrouped.
And by 1997, she
played a key role
in securing passage of the
Children's Health Insurance
Program, known as CHIP.
CHIP provided low-cost
health coverage
to millions of
American children,
an objective Clinton
cared about deeply.
And it served as a crucial step
toward more comprehensive care.
And Clinton also
used her standing
as First Lady of
the United States
to advocate for the
rights of women worldwide,
most famously declaring at the
United Nations Fourth World
Conference on women
in Beijing in 1995--
and I know Nick quoted, but
it's worth saying again--
"if there is one message
that echoes forth
from this conference, let
it be that human rights are
women's rights
and women's rights
are human rights
once and for all."
[APPLAUSE]
Having made about as much of her
First Ladyhood as anyone could
and as determined as ever to
solve the nation's problems,
in 2000, Clinton sought
a new role for herself
in elected office as the
senator from New York.
Back in Washington,
Clinton established herself
as a master of
complex policy details
and as a pragmatic deal maker.
Among her legislative
accomplishments,
Clinton helped secure billions
of dollars in federal aid
to rebuild New York after the
terrorist attacks of September
11, 2001.
She also fought to
provide health coverage
for 9/11 first
responders and was
critical to a bipartisan effort
to provide full military health
benefits to reservists
and National Guard
members, both important steps
towards her long-sought goal
of expanding Americans'
access to quality health care.
Clinton was re-elected in 2006.
And then in 2008, a year
I suspect everyone here
remembers well, Clinton ran
in the Democratic presidential
primary.
After her opponent, then
Senator Barack Obama,
secured enough delegates
to lock in the nomination,
Clinton worked hard to
unify the Democratic Party
and to help Obama win.
It was not in her
nature to do otherwise.
As she told her supporters,
"life is too short,
time is too precious, and
the stakes are too high."
When Obama was elected,
Clinton accepted his nomination
to serve as Secretary
of State, traditionally
the most prestigious
and important role
in the president's cabinet.
Our panel discussion
this morning
took as its starting point
Secretary Clinton's vision
for a new global architecture.
Clinton combined that vision
with the same awe-inspiring
endurance that she had
demonstrated so many times
before.
She became one of the most
effective and highly regarded
secretaries of state
in recent memory,
rebuilding fractured
relationships
and opening up
productive communication
with countries long ignored.
She also created
infrastructure to advance
human rights, women's
rights, and LGBTQ rights
around the world, bringing
democratic and pluralistic
values into the heart
of US foreign policy.
And Clinton became the most
traveled secretary of state
in history, visiting
112 countries
and engaging in the same kind
of shoe-leather diplomacy
on a global scale as she had
done when building alliances
at home.
When Hillary stepped down as
secretary of state in 2013,
she had the highest
favorability rating
of any secretary
of state save one
since those opinion polls
were introduced in 1948.
And then in 2016,
as we all know,
Clinton ran for
president a second time
and succeeded in
becoming the first woman
ever nominated by a major party.
[APPLAUSE]
So much has been said
about that election.
And you all witnessed
it for yourselves,
so I need not add much.
I will just make the
point that elections
are about more than winning.
They promote ideas.
They shape values.
They inspire new
national ideals.
Hillary's campaign
for president may not
have shattered that
highest glass ceiling.
But in that brutal race,
as in so many other battles
she has fought over
her career, she
applied her vast intellect
and determination
in breaking down barriers
on behalf of others.
Although a majority
of American voters
cast their ballots for her,
she did not get the job.
Nonetheless, over a
lifetime of public service,
Hillary Clinton has fully
demonstrated her commitment
to the presidential
oath she would
have taken to preserve,
protect, and defend
the Constitution of
the United States
for the benefit
of all Americans.
In "Song of Myself,"
Walt Whitman
wrote, "have you ever heard that
it was good to gain the day?
I also say it is
good to fall, battles
are lost in the same spirit
in which they are won."
I suspect Hillary
Clinton would agree.
We honor her today for all
of her battles won and lost.
And most of all, we celebrate
her for returning time
and again to the
battlefield of public life
to fight for human
rights, for equality,
for economic opportunity, and
for a pragmatic but principled
approach to governing this great
if sometimes vexing nation.
[APPLAUSE]
This afternoon, we will
have the opportunity
to hear more from
Secretary Clinton herself
when she converses with
Massachusetts Attorney General
Maura Healey.
As I mentioned earlier,
Healey is a 1992 graduate
of Harvard Radcliffe.
[APPLAUSE]
Like Clinton, Healey
dares to compete.
Here at Harvard, she
concentrated in government
and was a cocaptain of the
women's basketball team.
After graduating, Healey
was the starting point guard
for a professional basketball
team in Austria for two years
before she returned
to Massachusetts
to attend law school at
Northeastern University.
Healey took office as attorney
general in January 2015,
pledging to be the people's
lawyer and, in her words,
"be guided by the values of
responsiveness, inclusion,
and integrity."
A distinguished attorney,
a powerful advocate,
and a rising star
among her generation
of office holders, Maura
Healey is an ideal conversation
partner for Hillary Clinton.
But before that, we will hear
from another trailblazer,
Madeleine Albright,
who was the first woman
to serve as secretary of
state from 1997 to 2001, which
made her the highest-ranking
woman in the history of the US
government.
[APPLAUSE]
She started a
trend that led some
to ask-- when John
Kerry was nominated
to be Secretary of State--
whether a man could
serve effectively in that role.
And she has long
been a trusted friend
and colleague to our medalist.
Secretary Albright is also
a graduate of Wellesley,
and she went on to earn
master's and doctoral degrees
from Columbia University.
Before taking over
the State Department,
Albright had served as US
permanent representative
to the United Nations and
a member of the president's
cabinet from 1993 to 1997.
Today, she is the Michael
and Virginia Mortara Endowed
Distinguished Professor
in the Practice
of Diplomacy at the
Georgetown University
School of Foreign Service.
In 2012, Secretary
Albright deservedly
received the Presidential
Medal of Freedom.
I am thrilled that Madeleine
Albright is here with us today
to offer her personal tribute
to Hillary Rodham Clinton,
so please join me now in warmly
welcoming Secretary Madeleine
Albright.
[APPLAUSE]
- Dean Cohen, thank you so
much for the introduction.
And congratulations to you for
your incredibly great tenure--
really fantastic.
And Secretary
Clinton and members
of the Radcliffe Association,
distinguished guests,
thank you all for your warm
welcome, and happy Memorial
Day.
I'm delighted to
be here and will
presume to speak for
our guest of honor
in saying that nothing gives
Wellesley graduates more
satisfaction then receiving
an award from Radcliffe.
[APPLAUSE]
And I have to say--
just to continue
the Wellesley-Radcliffe
connection--
I'd like to point
out that Dr. Paula
Johnson, the president of
Wellesley, is here with us
today.
[APPLAUSE]
I have to say, nothing
will give me more pleasure
than to share with you a few
thoughts about Hillary Rodham
Clinton.
Of course, it will
not be a surprise
that I have a very
soft spot in my heart
for this wonderful woman.
Back in 1996, when the
period of great mentioning
was going on about who was
going to be secretary of state.
I didn't ever think I
would be secretary of state
because people said, how could
a woman possibly be secretary
of state?
And I now know that I would not
have been secretary of state
if it hadn't been for Hillary.
And the reason I know
that is President Clinton
said so publicly.
And what happened was that we
were actually traveling abroad,
and we were at a
foreign embassy.
And we used to have this thing
where I'd introduce Hillary,
and she would introduce him.
And he said that during this
period of great mentioning,
Hillary came to him.
And she would say, why
wouldn't you name Madeleine?
She is most in tune
with your views,
expresses them better than
anybody else, and besides,
it would make your mother happy.
So that is how I got to
be secretary of state.
And as I think many of
you here can attest,
there's nothing like a
good job recommendation
when you need it.
I had first met Hillary in
the 1980s when she was serving
on the board of the
Children's Defense Fund, which
has been mentioned was founded
by a really fantastic woman
and another recipient of the
Radcliffe Medal, Marian Wright
Edelman.
And this goes to show that
even at that early stage
in her career, Hillary was
fighting for social justice
and to help the disadvantaged.
In 1993, when I began serving
as America's ambassador
to the United Nations,
Hillary was First Lady.
Now, a lot of people
kidded about the fact
that she used to channel
Eleanor Roosevelt. And Eleanor
Roosevelt spent a lot of
time at the United Nations,
so Hillary would come
up and visit me a lot.
And we had a great time and got
to know each other very well.
It was wonderful
to introduce her
to the foreign delegates,
whom she impressed really
with her knowledge and her
passion for the issues.
Hillary and I also traveled
together internationally a lot.
And she did prove to be one
of the country's most valuable
representatives, because
everywhere she went,
she made friends for America.
Now, people have talked about
the Beijing Women's Conference.
And we know the quote,
but I have to tell you
what it was really like.
When I got there,
it was really crazy.
There were cab drivers who
were given white sheets
to throw over the lesbians.
There were those who
kept talking about people
that were lesbians.
And people would come
up and say, where
is this country of Lesbia?
We couldn't figure out anything.
There were a lot of
disabled people there,
and people didn't know
how to treat them.
It was really crazy.
So those of you
have given speeches
know how hard it can
be to grab and maintain
the attention of an audience.
So just imagine what it's
like when your listeners come
from 150 countries and are
sitting in front of you
with earphones
clamped to their heads
hearing the voices of
translators who speak slowly
and without emotion.
And we had been there
for a couple of days.
And then Hillary came
and spoke, and she
electrified the whole place.
She didn't openly offend
her Chinese hosts,
but neither did she weaken
her message even a slight bit.
She spoke with dignity
and courage of activists
across the globe
who were struggling
to be heard in places where
the only right most women were
granted was the right
to remain silent.
She spoke of women who
had been held back,
pushed aside, shoved
down, beaten up
for reasons that were ascribed
to tradition and culture.
And she insisted that there
was no reason of culture that
could excuse the
theft of human dignity
and no tradition that provided
a license for bigotry.
And in words that echoed
instantly across the globe--
and I will repeat it--
she declared simply
that human rights
are women's rights
and women's rights
are human rights.
Never before and never
since has a First Lady
inspired so many with an impact
that continues to this day.
And that statement
echoes everywhere
as I have traveled
everywhere, and it is still
the one that is
motivating so many people.
The following year, we
were on the road again.
And this time, we went to
Prague, Czechoslovakia,
the city of my birth.
And I'll never
forget the pride I
took in showing Hillary the
sights of the beautiful city.
But we also had an awful lot
of serious diplomatic business
to take care of and
at one point needed
to talk where foreign officials
and reporters couldn't hear us.
The result was another
landmark moment
in US diplomatic history--
the first official
foreign policy discussion
in the ladies' room.
[APPLAUSE]
We also had an
opportunity to march down
Wenceslas Square
with President Havel,
and Hillary and President Havel
had wonderful discussions.
And you can just
imagine how proud
I was to have that opportunity.
I also actually happen
to like Czech food,
so I took Hillary
to a restaurant.
And the thing I like
most of all is cabbage.
And so I went to the kitchen.
They're nice to me there
in the Czech Republic.
And I said, please keep
bringing out the cabbage.
And finally, Hillary
said, Madeleine,
I don't really
like this cabbage.
So that is one thing
we do disagree on.
It was in this
period that the world
came to realize what
friends already knew.
Hillary Clinton
was not just smart.
She was dedicated to helping
people across the globe.
And she was not just dedicated.
She was tough.
Her career has been guided
by John Wesley's admonition.
And I quote, "do
all the good you can
in all the ways you can.
And by Harriet Tubman's creed,
if you're tired, keep going.
If you're hungry, keep going.
And if you want a taste
of freedom, keep going."
Hillary Clinton is a unique
figure in American history.
No one else has been First
Lady, an award-winning author,
a mother now a grandmother, US
senator, secretary of state,
and the first woman nominee
of a major party for president
and who won all
the popular votes.
[APPLAUSE]
But her true
measure can be found
not in what she's been but in
the principles for which she
has stood.
She takes seriously the
words that symbolize what
this country is all about--
that all men and women
are created equal
and that our shared
purpose should
be to pursue liberty and
justice for everyone, regardless
of race, creed, gender,
sexual orientation,
or whether someone
arrived in this land
as an immigrant or
a refugee, which
is why I'm wearing the
Statue of Liberty today.
[APPLAUSE]
Hillary's dedication
is reflected
in the efforts she made on
behalf of universal health care
here at home and
the initiatives she
led abroad to foster peace,
reduce poverty, promote
human rights, and ensure that
the vital voices of women
are taken into account.
When Hillary Clinton represented
America as secretary of state,
we were confident that she
would strengthen our bonds
with allies, spur
progress in addressing
global threats such as
terrorism and climate change,
and speak eloquently
and effectively
on behalf of democratic values.
That is the kind of
leader Hillary is.
That is the kind of leadership
America will always need.
And it's why, in 2016,
I was proud to support
her candidacy for president.
I'm still excited by the
many thousands of volunteers
who worked so hard
for her campaign
because they believed that
America is strongest when we're
together and that we're
best when we look out
for one another and treat
each other with civility
and kindness.
Since the election,
we have all struggled
to understand the
forces that were
at work during the campaign.
And some of us have put
our thoughts in writing.
Hillary wrote a book
called What Happened.
And I-- well, Hillary is
more of a diplomat than I am.
The book I wrote is called
Fascism-- a Warning.
[APPLAUSE]
The good news is that
in recent months,
we've been witnessing the most
widespread and far-reaching
groundswell of political
activism and organization
in my lifetime.
Thousands of women
have stepped forward
to run for office
for the first time
and many of them
energized by Hillary
and supported by her new
organization, Onward Together.
None of them are
dwelling on the past.
Like Secretary Clinton, we
are focused on the future.
More than two decades
ago in Beijing,
Hillary urged us never to forget
that all people, and I quote,
"have the right to speak freely
and the right to be heard."
And thanks to Hillary's
example, voices are being heard
and will continue to be heard
on behalf of imperatives that
are anchored in the heart--
the love of justice, the
desire for freedom, the refusal
to remain silent in
the face of bigotry,
and the pursuit of veritas--
truth.
And now I ask you
to join with me
in thanking Hillary
Clinton for everything she
has done and will
do for our country,
for women, for men, and
for the future of us all.
So Hillary, if
you and Maura will
come up and take your places.
Thank you all very, very much.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Well, we have renewed
energy after that lunch.
This is a rowdy crowd.
This is wonderful.
Listen, I want to say very much
thank you to Dean Cohen and all
of the folks here at
Radcliffe Institute
and this entire
university who worked so
hard to make this day possible.
It's a real honor for
me to be here today
and a particular honor to be
here with Secretary Clinton
as she receives this so
richly-deserved Radcliffe
Medal.
We're going to get
right into it, I think,
because everybody's been
waiting for you to speak.
Maybe you could
start by telling us
how you felt when you got
the call that you were going
to be able to come to Radcliffe
today and receive this medal.
- Well, I really was
absolutely thrilled
because I have followed
over the years what
the Institute has done.
And as you've heard
earlier, a number
of women who I both
know and admire
have been on this stage
receiving the medal.
But I couldn't help but
think about my late father.
Because as you heard
from Liz, I don't
know where he got
this idea, but he
was convinced that
Radcliffe was filled
with what he called "beatniks."
So he did tell me I couldn't
go west of the Mississippi--
assuming I wanted him
to help pay for it--
or to Radcliffe.
So I ended up
applying to Wellesley.
I'd never been to
Wellesley before.
And so my parents drove me, and
we went through Harvard Square.
And just at the most
normal-looking person,
my father would say,
see, I told you.
It's filled with beatniks.
So, dad, here I am getting
the Radcliffe Medal.
[APPLAUSE]
- Well, maybe a good place
to start following Secretary
Albright's wonderful testimonial
and this amazing panel that we
were all experiencing
this morning--
that was just terrific.
[APPLAUSE]
I figured you might
have some thoughts--
perhaps some things to
amplify, even challenge.
But what's your
reaction to some of what
was talked about during
this morning's discussion?
- Well, first, I
couldn't imagine a more
distinguished and lively panel.
Nick, thank you for
putting it together
and for moderating it-- and
to each of the panelists.
I think what you heard is a
very fair discussion about where
we are in the world today
and an implicit challenge--
regardless of party, regardless
of region of our country--
about who we want
to be as a nation
and how we want to be
represented in the world
and how we choose
or not to lead.
So up on that panel were two
people that I've had a real
pleasure in working
with closely,
Anne-Marie and Michelle, another
whom I really admired her
commitment to her work--
Megan-- during the
Bush administration
was really legendary,
and a journalist
who doesn't just sit and think
about what he wants to opine on
but actually travels
to places like Raqqa
and has been doing that
for years and led by Nick,
one of our country's most
distinguished diplomats.
So as I listened
to them, I really
found no space to disagree with.
The hard part always
is, how do you
translate that into not
just policy but action?
And I'm hoping that perhaps
with this pause that
was described concerning
the North Korea
potential summit
and negotiations,
perhaps some of
those lessons will be
applied by this administration.
There's that famous old saying,
fail to plan, plan to fail.
And many of us who have
had the opportunity
to be involved with negotiations
or followed them closely--
we're quite skeptical
that pushing as quickly
as the administration did to get
a summit without the groundwork
being laid, without
really the expertise that
should be consulted being
part of that process
would be successful.
So now with this
pause, look, I want
to see our country succeed
as much as anybody.
And I'm hoping that there will
be a chance to regroup and see
if any of this is possible.
But as Nick knows,
as Madeleine knows,
we've been down this
road numerous times
with the North Koreans.
So we have to go in
with our eyes wide open
with a certain
amount of skepticism.
But that doesn't
undermine the need
to push as hard
as possible to see
if there is at this
point in their history
a real chance for a
different relationship
and to rein in and contain
their nuclear program.
So all in all, I was
just captivated by it.
I thought it was a
terrific discussion.
My press secretary who's
been with me since 2008
was shaking his head.
And I walked out, and I said,
Nick, what's the matter?
He goes, I've just never
heard so many people
say so many nice things
about you in a row.
- Well, enjoy it.
- You know that goes, Maura.
- It doesn't last long.
One of the things, though,
that I think the panelists--
we had a brief
breakfast this morning.
But the issue about
the pipeline--
how do we encourage people
to pursue foreign service?
How do we encourage
people in this time
to go into government when
good men and women are
so desperately needed?
How do we encourage those to
pursue public service where
there may be a question for some
about where power really lies?
Is it in the political sphere?
Is it in government?
Is it in business or elsewhere?
But any thoughts about that?
- Well, sure, because we hope to
be able to encourage successive
waves of people,
particularly young people,
to decide that they want to work
in government-- local, state,
or national, or even
with international bodies
but focusing particularly
on our federal government.
And the way that that is
done is by inspiring people
by modeling what
that looks like.
And there's been--
I think it's fair to say--
a lot of discouragement.
Madeleine was telling me that at
the School of Foreign Service,
where she is a
distinguished professor,
students are in the
School of Foreign Service,
but they don't want to go
into the Foreign Service.
There is a real concern that
borders on discouragement
from entering into
the civil service
or, in the case of
the State Department,
the foreign service.
So that has to be rebuilt.
Now, I'm hoping that the new
secretary of state-- who has
told me and others that he
intends to really try to
rebuild the State Department,
try to bring in and maybe
even bring back some
of the expertise and
experience that has been lost--
will follow through on
that and be permitted
to follow through on that.
It's not a question
of valuing expertise
over common sense or
personal experience.
It's all hands on deck.
If you're running an
agency of the government,
or indeed, if you're in the
White House in the situation
room, those decisions are
so knotty they wouldn't
get to the secretary of
state or the president
or the national security
advisor unless they
were difficult decisions.
And in that case, you want
to have as much information--
dare I say facts and evidence--
that you possibly could in
order to advise and then make
the best decisions.
There's no guarantee that
the decision you make
will be the right one.
You know, Maura, that I've
thought a lot about this.
But one of the most
amazing decision
processes I was
part of was being
in the very small group
advising President
Obama about whether to go
after a target in Pakistan
based on intelligence that it
could very well be where Osama
bin Laden was living or hiding.
It was by no means a
100 to nothing decision,
and it certainly
wasn't a decision
that could be made by
the gut of the president.
At the end of the day, after
everything was presented
and the intelligence
was red teamed
by two different intel
groups that were not
in the hunt for bin Laden
but had other expertise,
and it came back that
maybe it was 40% to 60%
accurate reliable, you
had to lay all that out.
You had to have robust
discussion, even disagreements,
which we did among that very
small group around the table.
And then you turn
to the president.
And you each give
your opinion based
on your understanding
of the facts
and the evidence, your
assessment of the risks.
And then, of course,
the president
has to make the decision.
There is no way
that I can imagine
important life-or-death
decisions being
made without that kind
of thoughtfulness.
And the State Department
has a deep reservoir
of people with experience
who will say, well,
if you say that,
that sounds like what
was said to his father.
And he's going to immediately
have a negative reaction.
Now, who would know
that other than people
who have been immersed in
the language and the culture
of another country?
So I'm hoping that
people who are currently
in the government who are
not political appointees
will stay as long as they
can fighting for facts
and evidence and our values.
And I hope that people--
if they are so motivated-- will
still go into our government.
Because this too shall pass, and
we're going to need a vigorous,
well-prepared, well
positioned federal government
to try to pick up the pieces.
- Well, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Let's shift now to more
on the domestic front.
And in particular, I
want to focus some time
on a couple of
groups of people--
first, the students.
And then I want to
talk about women
out there who are running in
record numbers for office.
But just weeks ago
on this very campus,
Parkland students came to town.
And I think we see this
incredible surge in energy
by young people all
across this country.
We've got high schoolers
and junior high schoolers
organizing walkouts here in
Massachusetts, for example.
What do you make of it,
and what would your advice
be to young people today?
- Well, I'm thrilled by
the activism we're seeing.
And the fact that one of
the most difficult issues we
confront is over our
tragically high rate of gun
deaths in this country
and the constant pattern
of mass shootings and what
we've seen in our schools
has ignited a level
of civic involvement
on the part of high school
students is thrilling.
And what the Parkland
students are trying to do--
and I'm very much
admiring of this.
They want to turn
common sense gun safety
laws into a voting issue.
Now, people will say,
well, it's always
a voting issue, isn't it?
Well, it is for the other side.
For the other side whipped
up by the exaggeration
and the hyperbole--
the hypocrisy even--
of the NRA and public figures,
even though it's a really small
minority of Americans--
and, frankly,
a minority of gun owners,
because both a majority
of Americans and a majority of
gun owners support common sense
gun safety laws--
but because the anti group
is so well-organized and so
intimidating and because there's
some history as to the price
politicians pay for
going up against them,
it remains a voting
issue only on one side
of the political ledger.
So what the Parkland students
are doing is to say, look.
Whatever else you care about--
you care about the economy,
you care about health care,
you care about education
and climate--
great.
But please move up your
priority list whether or not
we keep children and young
people and everyone alive.
Let's not overlook the fact
that Las Vegas happened.
People attending a country
music concert picked off--
more than 50 killed,
500 injured--
the Pulse night club in Orlando.
So the children and student
killings, from Sandy Hook
to now Santa Fe,
Texas, grip your heart
in such a horrible way.
And people get motivated,
but let's remember
that a lot of other totally
innocent people going
about their daily lives
are being murdered.
So taking this on is one of
the great public services
that the Parkland students
and others joining them
are performing.
But it won't matter
if people don't
vote against NRA-funded
candidates come November.
So they're trying to translate
this into a voting issue.
And I want to thank
your attorney general.
She was one of the
first people out
of the gate talking about
the need for common sense gun
safety measures.
[APPLAUSE]
- So we look at these
students-- high school,
college millennials.
They're out there in the
environment marching,
the Women's March here, on
the gun issue and the like.
Is there something
different, though,
that you think is happening
with these students--
their use of social media
or other things happening
that makes youth activism,
student activism maybe
translate into something more
meaningful and transformational
than we've seen with student
movements in the past?
Not to take away from student
movements in the past,
but do you have any
thoughts on that
and real consideration of that?
- Well, I think it's always
difficult to compare.
And, of course, my
frame of comparison
would be the 1960s where there
was a lot of student activism.
There were many students
involved in the civil rights
movement.
There were many, many
students involved
in the anti-war movement.
Increasingly, there were
students speaking out
about the women's movement.
So there was a
level of involvement
that we saw in the streets, in
the classroom, and teach-ins
and sit-ins and all kinds
of tactics that were used.
And we look back, and
we think, well, hey, we
passed civil rights
laws eventually--
not soon enough.
But eventually, the
Vietnam War ended.
And yeah, ultimately,
we got laws passed
and legal decisions, court
opinions rendered to knock down
barriers for women.
So I certainly think
there was a connection
between young people's
activism back then
and a lot of the changes
that have been taking place.
What I see today is different
in part because it combines
old tactics like marches--
the Women's March,
the March for Life,
so many other demonstrations
that people have been
waging and participating in--
and it uses social
media for organizing.
And as you say, that is
a different approach.
Now, I will hasten to point
out that in the absence
of buttressing social media
with real on-the-ground personal
connections, relationship
building, and organizing,
it will not be effective.
And I saw that firsthand.
When the panel was
talking earlier--
and I think David Ignatius was
talking about the Arab Spring.
I went to Cairo after
Mubarak stepped down.
I met with a large group
of the students who
had led the Tahrir
Square demonstrations,
and I asked them.
I said, so what is next for you?
And they looked at me like,
what a ridiculous question.
We've done what we came to do.
We got rid of Mubarak.
And I said, so what do
you think happens next?
And they said, well, we're
going to have a democracy,
and we're going to move
quickly into a better future.
And I said, OK.
Let me stop you there.
Are any of you planning
to run for office
in this new democracy?
No.
Are any of you planning to start
political parties to compete?
No.
So you've built up all
this social capital driven
by social media, but you're not
ready to take the next step.
And of course,
that's what I saw.
And I said to them--
I said, there are only
two organized groups
other than the Mubarak regime.
There are only two
organized groups
in Egypt, the Muslim
Brotherhood and the army.
So if you don't help to fill
the void that has now developed
because the 30-plus
year ruler is gone,
it's going to be a contest
between the Muslim Brotherhood
and the army.
And indeed, that's
what happened.
So when I look at social media
as a tool for bringing people
to demonstrations,
for signing petitions,
for attacking somebody online
for what they did or didn't do,
that's a part of it.
But in the end, it
really does come down
to how well you're organized,
whether you show up and vote,
and whether there are people
willing to get into the arena
as Dean Cohen referred to
with the reference to Teddy
Roosevelt earlier.
So I guess I am inspired,
and I'm optimistic.
But I want to be sure that
all this activity actually
leads to real change.
And that's what I
find really hopeful--
is the number of people,
particularly the number
of women, running for office.
And I started this
group Onward Together
to support groups that
are recruiting candidates
and funding fund
raising for them
and also taking on cause
issues because I want
to have as personal
relationship as I can
with the young people who are
trying to go to the next level.
And many of them are
both motivated by
and shocked by the outcome
of the 2016 election.
Some have a sense
of mission that
is just extraordinary to
take our country back.
But this doesn't
happen overnight.
And it's imperative
that young people--
and really all of us who
are on the side of change
in the so-called
resistance and opposition--
who want to change the course
of the Congress first in 2018,
state legislatures,
governors and the like
really get involved and
support everybody who's already
out there in the arena
to the best we can
and make sure they
actually participate
in the political process and
show up and vote in November.
[APPLAUSE]
- Your story and so much of
what we've heard recounted today
shows and demonstrates
your lifelong commitment
to girls, to women, to
empowering girls and women.
And I know to this day you
continue to receive letters
from girls all over the world.
I asked my niece.
I went right to the
source-- a nine-year-old--
and you inspired her.
And I said, what
would you like me
to ask Secretary Clinton today?
And she told me that she'd
like to know who inspired you
when you were a little girl.
- Wow.
That's a great question.
I love talking to
these little girls
between the age of four and 12.
On my book tour, they would
come with little pantsuits
and little fake poppet pearls.
And some of them would wear
their Wonder Women costumes.
Look-- I feel very much
indebted to my mother who
didn't have the opportunities
by any stretch that I've had
but who really both inspired
me and guided me and picked me
back up when I was knocked down.
I tell this story
in Living History.
There was a searing experience.
We moved from Chicago
to the suburbs.
And we were living in the
kind of classic 1950s suburbs
where the men were--
they all left in the
morning to go to work.
They were all World War II vets.
They had lived through
the Depression.
They had a pretty
common world view.
Our mothers all were at home.
None of them worked.
They were active in the
PTA and in the neighborhood
in the church doing things
on a volunteer basis.
So when I was four
years old and we
were in this new neighborhood,
it was filled with kids.
I mean, it really was.
The baby boom was on every
corner of every street.
So my mother would
get me dressed
and usually put a bow in
my hair and send me out.
And every day, I would
get knocked down.
I would get pushed around.
And I would go running and
crying back into the house.
This went on for weeks.
And they just decided that I
was the easiest victim around,
so why not?
And it was kind of a training
program for future bullies.
And so one day, I go as usual
running back into the house.
And my mother meets me.
And she says to me, there is no
room for cowards in this house.
Get back out there.
I thought I'd been
sent to my death.
I later learned she was like
hiding behind the dining room
curtains.
Because when I came
back out, those kids
were more surprised than I was.
So here's what they decided.
They decided that there
should be a fight--
a real, physical fight-- between
me and the four-year-old girl
who lived across
the street who came
from this big, raucous family.
So they make a circle,
and they push us both in.
I'm looking at her.
She's looking at me.
And so her brothers
are yelling at her,
knock her down, knock her down.
And so she starts pushing me.
So, I mean, this was
not just another fight.
This was whether I would
have a home and a family
for the rest of my life.
So I pushed back really
hard, knocked her down.
That, thankfully, was the end.
There was no weapons
or anything like that,
it was just kids pushing
each other around,
and she became my best
friend growing up.
So my mother was a role
model and an example,
even though her life was
so different from mine.
She was abandoned
by her parents,
thrown out by her
grandparents, was
working as a domestic in another
family's home when she was 13.
But in the funny way life
is, working in that home
really influenced
her life because it
was the first time she'd
ever been in a home
where the mother and the father
loved each other, where they
took good care of
their children,
and where the woman
she was working for
knew my mother wanted
to go to high school.
So they worked it out that
my mother could get up early,
get her chores done,
run to high school,
and run back and finish her
chores when she got back
from high school.
It sounds kind of harsh, but for
my mother it was a great gift.
So she was by far the
biggest inspiration.
But then as I learned
more about our history
and got exposed to
different people,
I remember being really
impressed with Margaret Chase
Smith, the senator from Maine.
And I didn't really
know a lot about her.
But I've got most of my
information about the world
from Life magazine,
which came every Friday.
So you'd come home from school,
and you'd lie on the floor.
And you'd look at the pictures
and maybe read the article.
And that's how I encountered
Margaret Chase Smith.
I learned more about
Eleanor Roosevelt.
It was a very rich
time to be exposed.
And I had fabulous teachers
in my public schools,
just great teachers, all of whom
gave me a tremendous education.
- We're going to move through
an incredibly quick lightning
round here, OK?
One question I did
want to ask you
is, if you could be a CEO
of any company right now,
what would you choose and why?
- Facebook.
[APPLAUSE]
I just want to add, it's
the biggest news platform
in the world.
We can listen to really
brilliant experienced writers
like David Ignatius and try
to keep up with the news.
But most people in our
country get their news--
true or not-- from Facebook.
Now, Facebook is
trying to take on some
of the unexpected consequences
of their business model.
And I, for one, hope
that they get it right,
because it really is
critical to our democracy
that people get accurate
information on which
to make decisions.
And so that's the one I'd pick.
- When was the last time
someone didn't recognize you?
- Well, I sometimes go--
- You actually remember?
- I do.
I sometimes try to go in
sort of a mini disguise--
put on a baseball cap.
It is a little hard when you
have Secret Service following
you around.
One time where I
lived in Washing
while I was
Secretary of State, I
came home to go for a walk one
night at like 9:30 or 10:00.
I was trying to power
walk down Mass Avenue.
And a woman passed me on
her bike, and she stopped.
And I caught up with her,
and she whispered to me.
She said, I have to tell you.
There's a man following you.
I said, oh, really?
Oh, OK.
So I was just in
Australia and New Zealand,
and we were in New
Zealand and seeing
some of the sights in Auckland.
And they have a new
fabulous 39-year-old woman
prime minister.
Not only that,
she's going to have
a baby in a couple of weeks.
So it's really quite exciting.
And so people did not
recognize me, which was great.
It's a nice respite.
- OK.
Speaking of travels-- best
ceremonial swag you ever
received on the job?
- Wow.
Well, the good stuff
you can't keep.
You get a lot when you're
a First Lady, a senator,
or a secretary of state.
Most other cultures--
gift giving
is a part of the culture, so
they have to give you a gift.
And despite our best efforts to
not go overboard, pretty soon
you realize you've
got to reciprocate.
So I always had
wonderful American crafts
and American-made products
and felt really positive
about that.
But they would give you
elaborate jewelry and really
expensive handbags and things.
You would say,
thank you very much,
and they would go
right in the archive.
So the stuff you could keep was,
I think, below like $25 or $50.
I can't remember--
if you wanted to.
And I gave a lot
of my stuff away.
I gave it to people who
worked in the State Department
if they wanted it.
So I always appreciated a
thoughtful, inexpensive gift,
because at least
you then would have
the option of maybe keeping
it or giving it away.
But usually, ceremonial swag--
I have more sweatshirts,
more hoodies.
I have an enormous number
of T-shirts of all kinds.
And I hope nobody minds
that they are mostly now
in the possession of
homeless people in New
York and elsewhere,
because what's
the point of my
having all of that?
And victims of domestic
violence-- because the women
leave their homes with
nothing, so anything that
can be done to give
them a wardrobe
and give them some necessities.
So it's just a funny experience.
When it first happens to you,
you don't know what to say.
Oh, no, no.
That's OK.
You don't have to give me that.
No, no.
We have to give you that.
I mean, I can't go back and
tell my king or my president
that you didn't take it.
Oh, OK.
I'll take it.
So it's a different experience
when you're in those positions.
- All right.
Well, turning to the
slightly more serious,
I know there are a lot of
people in the audience who
wish Chelsea well, and
Charlotte, and your grandson
and are also looking
for some advice
on how to raise strong girls
and women in today's world.
Do you care to say
anything to that?
- Well, any of you
who have children
know that you can do everything
you think you should do,
and it doesn't work.
And you can also try different
approaches, different methods,
and some of it may.
I really am grateful
for the experience
of raising my daughter.
I think she's taught me as
much as I've ever taught her.
And what's a real joy
is now watching her
with my grandchildren.
I want to say just one word.
There's a lot of things that--
we read, talk, and
sing to your child.
Build those brain cells.
I mean, there's a lot of
very practical advice.
But I want to just mention
one area that I feel really
strongly about,
and that is we need
to develop empathy and kindness
in our children for themselves
and for others.
I was really fortunate.
Because when I was very
young, through my church,
I had a lot of
those experiences.
I was 12 years old
and asked to babysit
for the children of
Mexican farm workers
who were working their way
north with the harvest.
And a group of us girls
would go out to their camp
and watch the little kids
of the mothers and fathers,
and the older brothers and
sisters could work on Saturday.
And so at that very
young age, I got
to experience what to me
seemed like a total revelation.
Oh, my gosh.
They're just like us.
Because when their
parents would pull up
at the end of a long
dusty road in an old
beat up bus coming
back from the fields,
no matter what game
we were playing
or how we were entertaining the
kids, they would break loose.
And they would start running
as fast as they could
into the arms of their parents,
into throwing their arms
around the legs of their
big brothers and sisters.
And I thought about
myself as a child
running to meet my father
when he got home from work.
And so it's not as easy
perhaps now as it used to be.
But creating
opportunities for children
to learn the
importance of service
to understand the importance
of kindness and empathy--
so with Chelsea,
we would take her
to homeless shelters and
domestic violence shelters
and be part of the service
that we believed in that we
wanted her to experience.
So there's many ways of trying
to raise strong, bright kids,
but I hope we can raise
strong, bright, kind,
and empathetic kids as well.
[APPLAUSE]
And I know-- this
will be the last.
I know.
Because we do want to make
sure you get your medal.
In this time where
we know we need
to fight for the
rule of law, we need
to stand for the
Constitution, and we
need to enforce rights that are
on the books to protect people,
we need to fight
for a free media.
We need to fight for facts and
knowledge and data to guide us.
These are things I think a
lot of folks in this room
are actively engaged in.
But I guess my final question
for you, Secretary Clinton,
is, why are you optimistic and
hopeful as we look forward?
And specifically,
what is it that we
can be doing in our
day-to-day lives
or encouraging
others to do who are
looking to find their agency
in this critical moment?
You have taught us so much.
You have brought
so much forward.
I think about the activism
and the town halls,
the women who are
running for office,
the women you've inspired.
And there are so many ready to
go and ready to do the work.
But what work do you
think is meaningful,
and how should we
all get to work?
- Oh, that's a really important
question that I hope all of us
are thinking about,
because there's
something for everyone to do.
Not everyone will
want to run for office
or run a campaign or
volunteer for a campaign,
but there's something
for everyone to do.
And let me just sort
of briefly refer
to Madeleine with that
incredible book she has just
published, Fascism-- a Warning.
At the end of it, she talks
about what is expected from us.
If you see something, say
something, do something, right?
So what does that mean?
Well, we have to defend
higher education.
I'm sorry to have to say that,
but it is absolutely true.
And that doesn't mean
we defend the folks who
are not worthy of defense.
There are some
characters out there
who call themselves
colleges, and maybe that
should not be given the name.
But by and large,
higher education
is one of the greatest
accomplishments of the United
States.
It has been one of our
biggest selling points.
And we have attracted people
from all over the world.
We have educated
generations of Americans
to pursue their own dreams,
to contribute to society.
So please, anybody associated
with Harvard or Wellesley--
as my dear friend President
Paula Johnson knows--
stand up and defend
the open inquiry.
Stand up and defend
reason and facts.
Stand up against
alternative reality
wherever it pokes
up its ugly head.
Be ready to speak up about the
importance of the work that
is done at a great
institution like this.
Defend the press.
And believe me, that's not easy
for me to say all of the time.
But I know very
well in the absence
of a free, vigorous
press, our democracy
is not going to survive.
And what I see happening
is, unfortunately, we
have seen a kind of
rejuvenation of some
of our great newspapers.
Subscribe to a newspaper
for goodness' sakes
if it's one that is actually
coming back and doing
the investigatory work
trying to call out the truth.
But it's also the
fact that, as I said,
Facebook is the
major source of news.
And people who have a very
particular point of view,
an ideology, or a commercial
perspective to try to sell
have really dominated
the TV market.
It's not just Fox.
It's now Sinclair where
they are essentially
delivering propaganda.
So we need more people to
speak up and speak out,
and we need more outlets.
We need more sources of
reliable information.
I don't blame citizens for being
confused about what to believe.
They are bombarded day in and
day out by contrary messages.
And people kind of fall back on
relying on one or two sources.
And if they are
sources that don't
traffic in the facts,
then how can they
be expected to make
decisions that might further
our common efforts?
And finally, I know this is
another really obvious thing
to say--
vote in every election, not
just presidential election.
[APPLAUSE]
It is maddening because--
one of the panelists said,
we get the government
that we vote for.
Now, we have this odd system
with the electoral college.
And maybe we could
get President Faust
to explain the roots
of that, because it's
a little troubling.
But nevertheless, we've got it.
I've been against
it, by the way,
since 2000, not that
you need to know that.
But I have been
because I just think
it is absolutely contrary
to one person, one vote.
So you've got to find an issue
that you really care about
and go deep and go long.
We're not going to
change things overnight.
And we have to be persistent
and sustain the opposition
that we are now putting forth.
Actually, I've been
pleasantly surprised
how well it has been sustained.
So I can encourage people
to find that area that you
are passionate about and find
others who share your views
and then figure out a way to
talk about it, write about it,
speak up about it.
Because you never know
how the tide will turn.
And I am optimistic
the tide will turn.
Because once you
have a record, people
can actually measure what
you have delivered for them
and for their families.
And I think we'll
be in good shape
in making the case in
2018 and then in 2020
for politics that is rooted in
evidence about what works best
and in bringing
people together to try
to make common cause to actually
get the results we seek.
But that won't happen
just by wishing for it.
So please, everybody,
find a role
that you feel
comfortable playing.
[APPLAUSE]
- Well, we're going to bring--
this is a conversation I
would love to continue.
I'm sure many of you
would love to continue
to hear from Secretary Clinton.
But suffice it to say, it's
on to the medal ceremony.
And thank you.
I know I'm comfortable
speaking on behalf of all of us
in thanking you for your
inspiration, your integrity,
your commitment,
and your commitment
to making sure that no matter
the circumstance or what
befalls us we got to get up
every day and do the hard work,
the long and deep work, and that
together, we will move forward.
Thank you very much,
Secretary Clinton.
[APPLAUSE]
- So thank you so much,
Maura, for leading
such a terrific and
thoughtful conversation.
And to Secretary
Clinton, thank you
for sharing your thoughts,
your insights with all of us
and for participating in
this special occasion.
And in a minute, I'm going
to confer on you the 2018
Radcliffe Medal.
But before I do that.
I want to recognize someone who
has delayed in getting here.
But he was so determined to
get here that he persisted.
And that is former Harvard
President Neil Rudenstine,
who was critical to the
creation of the Institute.
[APPLAUSE]
The Radcliffe Institute
wouldn't be here today
if Neil hadn't persisted.
So now it's time for
me to read the citation
and then to give you our medal.
She has lived a life
of public service.
She uses her fierce
intellect and determination
to create meaningful social
and political change.
She displays the courage
demanded of those who go first.
Secretary Clinton, I bestow
upon you this Radcliffe Medal
with the deepest admiration for
a lifetime of exemplary service
and profound impact.
[APPLAUSE]
Now please join me in
welcoming our 2018 Radcliffe
Medalist Hillary Rodham
Clinton to the podium.
[APPLAUSE]
- Oh, thank you.
You know, this has been
such an amazing day.
I just want to express my
deep honor and appreciation.
Thank you so much to Dean
Cohen and to everyone
who was part of this
ceremony and who is part
of the Radcliffe Institute.
I am so humbled to accept
the Radcliffe Medal.
I want to thank formally
my friend and colleague
Madeleine Albright for her
remarks and for her leadership
and also to Attorney
General Healey
for that invigorating
conversation, which I agree,
Maura, could go on and on.
And I hope to keep
talking to you
as you keep doing an
excellent job-- not
only for Massachusetts,
but for the country.
[APPLAUSE]
Now, I have to
confess, being here has
felt a little bit like an
episode of that old TV show,
This Is Your Life.
But today's
conversation could not
have come at a more
important moment.
Transformation of our economy,
our politics, and our culture
is happening in real time.
I recently reread those
really famous lines
from Charles Dickens in
A Tale of Two Cities,
but I hadn't focused on them
in quite a number of years.
Just remember how it went.
"It was the best of times,
it was the worst of times.
It was the age of wisdom, it
was the age of foolishness.
It was the epoch of belief, it
was the epoch of incredulity.
It was the season of light,
it was the season of darkness.
It was the spring of hope, it
was the winter of despair."
Now, Dickens was obviously
writing about the years
leading up to the
French Revolution,
but he could have
been describing
the ricocheting highs and lows
of this moment in America.
Because we're living
through a time
when fundamental rights, civic
virtue, freedom of the press,
even facts and reason are under
assault like never before.
But we are also witnessing an
era of new moral conviction,
civic engagement,
a sense of devotion
to our democracy
and our country.
One of my heroes, Eleanor
Roosevelt, said many things,
but here's one.
"You gain strength and
courage and confidence
by every experience
in which you really
stop to look fear in the face.
And you are able
to say to yourself,
I have lived
through this horror.
I can take the next
thing that comes along."
That's resilience.
Resilience has been
on my mind a lot,
because everyone
gets knocked down.
What matters is whether you
get back up and keep going.
And it's not been an easy
time for more than half
of our country since
the 2016 election.
And I still think
that understanding
what happened in that
weird and wild election
will help us defend our
democracy in the future.
Now, you know-- and you heard
this morning from the panel--
our country is
dangerously polarized.
We have sorted ourselves
into opposing camps,
and that shapes so much
about how we see the world.
The data backs this up.
There are more liberals and
conservatives than there
used to be and fewer centrists.
Our political parties
are more ideologically
and geographically consistent.
There are fewer
northern Republicans
and fewer southern Democrats.
The divides on race and religion
are starker than ever before.
And as the middle shrank,
partisan animosity grew.
In 1960, just 5% of
Republicans and 4% of Democrats
said they would be upset if
their son or daughter married
a member of the other
political party.
Now, in 2010, the number
was 49% of Republicans
and 33% of Democrats
who felt that way.
So I don't want
to get political,
but I want to say this is not
just a both sides problem.
The radicalization
of American politics
has not been symmetrical.
There are forces and
leaders in our country
who blatantly incite people
with hateful rhetoric, who
stoke fear of change, who see
the world in zero-sum terms
so that if others are
gaining, then everyone else
must be losing.
So that is a recipe for
polarization and conflict.
And I do believe that
healing our country
will take what I call
radical empathy--
reaching across the
divides of race, class,
but mostly politics to try to
see the world through the eyes
of people very
different from ourselves
and to try to return
to rational debate,
to find a way to disagree
without being disagreeable,
to recapture a sense
of common humanity.
When we think about politics
and judge our leaders,
we can't just ask, am I better
off than I was four years ago?
We should also ask,
are we all better off?
Are we as a country better,
stronger, and fairer?
And empathy should not
only be at the center
of our individual lives, our
families, and our communities
but at the center of our
public life, our policies,
and our politics.
I know we don't think
of politics and empathy
as going hand in
hand these days.
But they can, and they must.
As Madeleine writes
in her new book,
"this generosity of spirit,
this caring about others
and about the proposition
that we are all created equal
is the single most
effective antidote
to the self-centered
moral numbness
that allows fascism to thrive."
So in addition to the
kinds of resilience
that have been on my mind and
that I've been talking about,
I'm also very focused on
democratic resilience.
You all remember-- in 1787 after
the Constitutional Convention
in Philadelphia,
Benjamin Franklin
was asked by a
woman in the street
outside Independence Hall,
well, Doctor, what have we got?
A republic or a monarchy?
And Franklin answered, a
republic if you can keep it.
So right now, we are
living through a crisis
in our democracy.
There certainly are not
tanks in the street,
but what's happening
today goes to the heart
of who we are as a nation.
And I say this not
as a Democrat who
lost an election but
as an American afraid
of losing a country.
And there are
certain things that
are so essential they
must transcend politics.
Waging a war on the rule
of law and a free press,
delegitimizing elections,
perpetuating corruption,
rejecting the idea
that our leaders should
be public servants,
undermining our national unity,
and attacking truth and reason--
these should alarm
us all, whether we're
Republicans, Democrats,
Independents, vegetarians,
whoever we might be.
And attempting to erase the line
between fact and fiction, truth
and an alternative
reality is a core feature
of authoritarianism.
The goal is to make us
question logic and reason
and sow mistrust toward
exactly the people I
think we need to rely on--
our leaders, the
press, experts who
seek to guide public policy
based on evidence, ultimately,
ourselves.
Now, just last week,
former Secretary of State
Rex Tillerson said,
"if our leaders seek
to conceal the truth or we
as people become accepting
of alternative realities
that are no longer grounded
in facts, then we as
Americans are on a pathway
to relinquishing our freedom."
Perhaps a tad late, but
he's absolutely right.
So how do we build
democratic resilience?
Well, Maura and I talked
a little bit about that.
It does begin with standing
up for the truth, facts,
and reason--
not only in the
classroom and on campus,
but every day in our lives.
And it means speaking
out about the vital role
of higher education in our
society to create opportunity
and equity.
It means calling out actual
fake news when we see it
and supporting brave
journalism and reporting--
and yes, subscribing
to a newspaper.
Remember those?
Most of all, as
obvious as it seems,
it means voting in
every election, not just
the presidential ones.
We've come through
challenging times before,
and it's not easy to wade
back into the fight every day.
But that's exactly
what we must do.
And finally, that's why I am
optimistic about the future--
because of how unbelievably
tough we are proving to be.
I've encountered many
people in recent months
who give me hope--
the students in Parkland,
now the students in Santa Fe,
many people in communities
who have responded
with courage and resolve.
And the leaders and
groups that I'm supporting
have given me a
real rush of hope.
Because when I started
it after the election,
it was to help support
this rush of activity
from the grassroots level
to encourage the outpouring
of that engagement--
so everyone who is marching,
registering voters, diving
into the issues facing
us like never before--
some for the first
time in their lives,
the leaders here at
the Radcliffe Institute
doing cutting-edge
research bringing together
some of the brightest minds in
the world to discuss and debate
big ideas.
And yes, I find hope in the
wave of women running for office
and winning.
And I find hope in
the women and men
who are dismantling
the notion that women
should have to endure harassment
and violence as a part of life.
[APPLAUSE]
So, yes, I know there
are many fights to fight,
and more seem to
arise every day.
And it will take work
to keep up the pressure
and to stay vigilant
to neither close
our eyes nor numb our
hearts or throw up our hands
and say, someone else
take over from here.
But there has not been a time--
certainly in 50 years and maybe
not even for longer than that--
where our country depends
on every citizen believing
in the power of
your actions, even
when that power is invisible
and your efforts feel like you
are in an uphill battle--
and yes, voting, even
when your side loses.
It comes down to be really
a matter of infinite faith.
So pace ourselves.
Lean on each other.
Look for the good
wherever we can.
Celebrate the heroes.
Encourage children.
Find ways to disagree
respectfully.
Be ready to lose some
fights, but don't quit.
As John McCain
recently reminded us,
no just cause is futile,
even if it's lost.
What matters is
that we keep going.
So no matter what,
think about our children
and our grandchildren
who are counting on us.
And think, too, that our country
and the world are as well.
Thank you so much,
Radcliffe and Harvard.
[APPLAUSE]
- OK.
I just want to say,
I want to thank
Secretary Clinton one
more time for this really
remarkable, inspiring day.
I want to thank Nick
and our panelists who
were incredibly stimulating and
gave us so much to think about.
And I want to thank all of
you for coming and making
this historic Radcliffe
day so memorable.
So on to the future.
- Yes, onward!
[MUSIC PLAYING]